heute bevor der block anfänglich war ich
ganz schön sagen und zwar ist es einer
meiner ersten loks in zukunft wird es
davon öfter mal sowas geben und ich
werde öfter halten auch morgen weist dem
mega viel spaß gemacht habt also ganz
wichtig wenn es das ganze gefällt oder
wenn ihr es cool findet wenn zu den
behältern laster bitte auf jeden fall
nach oben da also haben jetzt schon
samstag das ganze schon passiert ich hab
das ganze schon zusammengestellten bars
für 35 stunden dran und mir gefällt
persönlich eigentlich ziemlich gut ich
bin mega zufrieden schreibt auch keine
kommentare irgendwelche kritik was euch
nicht gefällt was ich besser machen kann
und jetzt viel spaß würde ich an philipp
[Musik]
glaubt netz bekommen beim ein video
ja weil ich habe mir heute mal so einen
gorilla gingen runter geschraubt weiß
ich kann ich das ja ganz fein dem
spiegel
also dass sie zu haus und zwar gleich
das mit dem bloggen ist irgendwie so
deutlich einfacher
auf jeden fall geht heute nach
düsseldorf zum lobpreis ich nehme ich
natürlich merkt wie man hier sieht
ich bin gerade noch dabei und zwar
vermutlich mein hemd etwas wasser zu
bekommen ich habe es total fertig dass
ich gar kein cooles sam tja
deswegen muss ich das ist irgendwie so
provisorisch bügel und ich muss mich
auch mega beeilen weil ich gerade noch
ein video gedreht habe ich gegen habe
unter vorgeladen hat wir müssen uns
jetzt erstmal umziehen und dann ist
direkt vom lohn es ist 23 nach 1 und die
bahn kommt um 14 uhr
also würde ich sagen der slowup letzten
8 ultra wenig geschlafen weil ich müsste
nur noch bayern musste videos klagen und
so weiter und so fort jetzt wird sich
das musikangebot aber bin ich bei der
katze rich das man braucht um einen
schätzen knapp vor dem wieder zeit dafür
habe ich auch nicht ich musste jetzt so
improvisieren er immer das gleiche ich
und einfach viel zu klein
[Musik]
ich bin komplett eingekleidet eigentlich
brauche ich noch weiße sorten problem
ich habe keine weißen doch mehr hier
deswegen nehmen wir es einfach spaß es
ist einfach so warm ich nehme einfach
gar keine also ich würde eigentlich
gerne diese weißen schuhe anziehen habe
ich geschenkt bekommen dann kein outlets
46 punkte nun die muss ich glaube ich
vorher noch mal ein bisschen wurden so
leute die sachen schuhe sind das jetzt
nicht
aber seit ich auch wieso leute aufgeht
ich bin auf jeden fall sehr gespannt und
ich freue mich so viele mal wieder zu
sehen
ich hab schon so lange nicht mehr
gesehen denn diese fragte sich jeden tag
dass ich kein bock mehr drauf deswegen
ein paar andere youtuber ist auch mal
wieder ganz gut also bis gleich er hat
gesagt ich bin immer so nett zu ihm in
den videos für jedes mal machte mission
veränderten video mit 99 99 euro
hier kommt in diesem fenster an das
läuft alles nach unten weil die so
halten sechs backwerk ich habe einfach
nie gegessen und ich finden kann und so
viele komische menschen es zum beispiel
der oper im hintergrund vielleicht dem
sehen könnt der ruf die ganze zeit da
packt er sich den arsch kläger sie
kommen anders aussieht wie wird man so
ich verstehe das nicht
selber
[Musik]
oberrot von zuvor 3
[Applaus]
euro
dirk u
alle schuld daran weil schulden die
geister so leute bedienten düsseldorf
angekommen bei düsseldorf derendorf
let's go angespannt freue mich alex man
mehr krieg ich das dorf in videogames
gearbeitet
wir haben noch vier minuten kommen dann
auf ja von mir machen tempo erwartet
einfach wagen überhaupt
unser fenster unterlaufen
so leute wir sind hier beim die story
soll auf jeden fall wagen hat im taxi
ich zur iss dome ist da dann der
taxifahrer kurz gesagt du für hügel
storm und lass dich so ist kaputt und
wir sitzen da und denke so witzig war es
jetzt auch nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
richtig auch nicola leute wir fahren
jetzt habe ich klar warum auch immer
so leute berliner was geht schöne grüße
von mir der geburt weil ich wünsche dir
alles gute
feier schön und lass dich reichlich
beschenken das hat mir von euch locker
bis hin zu vielen aber nicht laune
[Musik]
rheingold
derzeit gehören
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so leute wir sind hier in der halle oder
die liebste in halle ins tor verlängerte
meine lieblingsbücher kleckern und der
heißt für mich absolut den content
[Musik]
also ich hätte das eindeutig schneller
geschafft war mir eine freude immer
gesund leben aller aller geschickt
[Applaus]
auf jeden fall cool herd vergessen
migranten machen und wir fahren jetzt
zur after-show-party so loidl es tor zur
after show party
wir sind jetzt hier auf jeden fall in
düsseldorf am rheinauhafen und jetzt
gucken wir mal ob man hier coole fotos
machen kann weil ich finde ich sie heute
wieder so verdammt gut auf das richtige
format findet dieser ecke genau der
rhein ist so leute also man muss sagen
es sieht auf jeden fall ganz cool aus
fast nur was man sagen kann alle diente
hüter von kölns eindeutig schöner nicht
nur der rein sondern irgendwie alles so
hier kann man auf jeden fall dass einmal
eine gute kriegsschiffen aus der von mir
du bist immer hässlich so leute werden
wir auf jeden fall die herzlichsten
bilder gemacht ich bleibe mal so ein 21
vielleicht auf jeden fall geht es los
wir müssen mal gucken wo das reingeht
wird das schon ziemlich dunkel das ding
ist auf der aftershow welt natürlich
nicht wirklich locken weil viele youtube
sich volllaufen werden lassen und das
ist natürlich nicht gut werde aber wie
finde ich bin absolut nicht
alkoholischer noch arbeiten müssen wir
hart arbeiten
[Musik]
später wieder eine lange nacht
nein
foto jp morgan leiter wir haben gerade
einfach irgendwie 6 uhr morgens kam mit
der bahn zurück nach köln gefahren
ich habe ja noch die rosarote brille auf
und ich muss das schlaflager ich finde
es auf jeden fall 24 durch könnt euch
mal diese fakten welt und aus plastik
immer ehrlich sagen in der video preis
fand ich nicht so spannend
ja es war auf jeden fall witzig durch
jesus ist egal gefangenen zu den taxi
nach hause alex teil für das paket auf
meinen nacken
es ist einfach herrlich habe jetzt
ungefähr keine ahnung also den letzten
48 stunden und reisten geschlafen also
irgendwie fast gar nicht wenn überhaupt
drei stunden wir können auf jeden fall
auch nicht so lange kennen weil wir
gleich eine wohnungsbesichtigung haben
wir wollen wieder umziehen ich habe der
blogger recht gefallen
er hat ein bisschen unterhalten was auf
jeden fall nach oben da abgab seines
ganzen mit kiwi die beschreibung website
und instagram ab und wir sind rein